okay hey guys we don't know now you know
your life it's different now
I'm here with Kristin hi we did a video
just now on her channel that you guys
should go watch after this we made
prison food I don't feel good I mean I
would say that's why I'm dressed this
way but honestly I'd leave it normally
I thought Christian would be really fun
to talk through the MTV EMA's yeah
European Music Awards I'm assuming is
what that stands for that makes sense
sure I didn't know this is the thing
until now I didn't know it was a thing
until I saw it on Twitter I don't know
music so we are going to review this
happened over the weekend some of the
red carpet fashions from the EMA's first
have Camila Cabello is that yeah as I
say your name
Camila kebaya the girl that left fifth
harmony I mean one there's a lot there's
a lot of beautiful saran-wrap seemingly
happening in this photo she's got a
corset but it also looks like you know
those bras that you wear that are just
sticky bras and she's got straight-up
what looks like a plastic bag wrapped
around her neck honestly at the top yeah
where you tie the bag when you're taking
it out to the trash the bottom half
looks a little bit like grandmother's
nightie but she also does look like a
porcelain doll so true kudos but this
part just makes me feel anxious that
she's suffocating because that's what I
was thinking because I look at it as a
plastic bag too like she's a plastic bag
around her neck we all learn not to do
that for putting anything in but your
head Demi Lovato whoa oh my god she
looks so good super badass she looks
like Demi Moore so much here yes she's a
fit the long black hair and her body and
skin looks photoshopped but she also
looks like the sexiest like Nantucket
businessman I've ever seen how can you
make that sexy we got that true p.m.
I always fear open things like that
because it's it's tough with fashion
table like if you sweat too much your
skirt if you hug the wrong way the wind
blows too hard
I like when girls wear masculine
clothing yes me too and make it like
really sexy and she really is she always
looks so angry fierce but a good thing
that she's probably we're having really
expensive shoes that we can't see she
won with Crocs and it'd be fine that
would be hilarious financial
irresponsibility next we have Rita Ora
dawn she hosted the EMA's okay I'm
obsessed with this whole look she's
showing up like she just got out of the
most elegant shower of all time in Oz
but she's wearing the same jewels I am
she was like running late and was like I
don't give a [ __ ] I'm Rita Ora
I'm hosting the event this is what we're
doing and I kind of love this so much
that's where I aspire to be sexy is good
though sure I know that's the confusing
thing is I think how is she wearing just
a towel on her head and she looks so
sexy this feels like this would be the
most amazing like Marriott commercial
she's so comfy she's great good for her
she's changed now I have Shawn Mendes so
I know this is when you watch sitcoms
and the first season there's like a
little boy of any kind the fourth season
it's uncomfortable to watch him because
you're watching her go through puberty
and he's one of those people that use
their age never changes right that he's
in the blurry zone that you're like I'm
not gonna even like think about him no
that's not a person that I should be
wondering what the ages but that's cool
though my prince yeah they're gonna it's
fun and distracting yes I think this is
cool cuz he is a musician but he looks
like he could be like a boring white boy
you would look at him and say that's
like an Abercrombie and Fitch model that
perfume not gonna be interesting and
then you find out that he's super
musically talented
this is giving him that cool music in a
couple I think Susan Boyle
some might say Shawn Mendes is the Susan
Boyle of young up-and-coming male
musicians he's doing a stylish look
without being like over the top yes and
it still seems subtle weirdly enough now
we have Haley Baldwin I thought that was
Gigi Hadid I don't know people she's
around Gigi and all those girls fair
that I got mixed up then yes she's act
like every young person award show event
and she always looks sad oh she does she
always looks like her dad told her she
can't go to prom wait is this the one
that's dating no that are you having a
stroke no that's Gigi Hadid okay I like
this dress I like sugary
yeah she's got oil poured all over her
which is cute his shoes are cool they're
like choking your ankles chokers for
your ankles yeah Oh
Jared Leto it looks like Borat met Dora
the Explorer and this is the final
outcome and also I think he's wearing
could be worth the Pedic shoes but I
think through the new Kanye West's
sneaker it's very much like 80s prom
date on the top and then like retired
Italian man on the bottom
wow that's I mean it's a look it's a
combo oh look yeah but I don't hate it
okay this is long ago ray I really like
that dress though that's really cool it
screams gardening yeah she always just
looks like she doesn't talk but I think
this dress is really cool again and
still appropriate yes it's so loud but
it's somehow still very like compared to
read aura okay this is Liam Payne that's
a normal fit uh it's fine it yeah he
looks like I'm wonderful he's probably
sweating yeah he looks like both of his
arms are paralyzed yes or that he just
came from like skiing but then also a
funeral before that he looks like
constipated like it's like I shard it
the orange is fine but I don't know to
me it just seems like a little
connected did I just give an opinion
orange
this is Charli XCX I didn't I never had
a face to that name Amex comfy I mean
this could be the same outfit that Liam
Payne is wearing under that shirt we
just don't know cute couples costume
like a sexy mine happening right now yes
it's like crop top painting teacher
painting the answer as an art teacher
maybe okay this is Madison beer this is
a look I gets up on the inter food I
know pushed so high and do the straps
say something I can't tell but it's just
making me look more at her boobs this is
Christian Oh is she a Christian is that
the messaging but it's like right next
to her did she like I'm secretly hoping
she's just letting everyone know that
she's the Christian and it's directly
next to here now look at my religion my
religion is down here how dare you know
this is Travis Scott but you look here
yeah I can't tell what's on the jacket
it's like a jack-in-the-box but like a
ghoul is coming out of it
the pants look like the pants that you
unzip at the knees yeah they look like
the pants that the kids that played D&D
in high school wore I think um Charma
Scott is Kylie Jenner's rumored baby
daddy ah oh he looks like he just put a
baby in someone the rumors are confirmed
you heard it here first
this is what dads are wearing in 2017
this is Julia Michaels she's cool okay
this is a confusing look because it's
like one pant leg and then a skirt I
wrapped around the other one which seems
like it would be very uncomfortable and
jarring to wear I have pants on but no i
don't i also have my cooter hanging out
and go this this was not breathable but
chic but very chic and she also looks
like the kind of girl that like I want
that girl to be my friend she looks like
a badass that would like really tear
someone down if it was with me but then
I feel like you talk to her and she's so
nice yeah but she looks unapproachable
and then she's just like so sweet now
we're just judging her personality and
not hurt
okay so last one Kesha this is a screams
Tik Tok yeah dreams like old Kesha yeah
which I really like it's a weird face
galaxy unicorn cowboy look boys it's
like mermaids space cowboys yeah it's
like your aunt that lives in Texas like
went off the grid and did a bunch of LSD
and then came back I was like this is
who I am now
literally it's all her normal clothes
but just shiny well there we go
Wow that was our review of the EMAs over
I think Goods and that's everybody
express themselves and that's all that
matters truly I can't really say
anything negative about any of it
because they're all I've put much more
effort and time and thought into their
looks and clearly I ever do and though
they're there and we're not that's true
they're invited to these things and were
sitting back just judging them because
we're jealous if you guys want to feel
not so jealous of us eating delicious
meals go over to Kristen's Channel I
watch the video where we tried to make
prison foods it was interesting and I
learned a lot about myself
we both should probably head to our
respective homes to use the restrooms at
some point in the soon future yes thank
you guys so much for watching on that I
don't know okay this is I forget this
girl's name oh yeah Sabrina Sabrina no
carpenter okay so apparently it's a big
musician I don't know she has a cute
butt yeah that's great moving on